we like to think that
we we like to view the world as linear
which is
i'm gonna put in eight hours of work i'm
gonna get back eight hours of output
right it doesn't work that way a guy
running the corner grocery store is
working just as hard or harder than you
and me how much output is he getting
what you do who you do with how you do
it way more important than how hard you
work right outputs are
non-linear based on the quality of the
work that you put in the right way to
work is like a lion you don't you and i
are not like cows we're not meant to
graze all day right we're meant to hunt
like lions we're closer to carnivores in
our omnivorous development than we are
to herbivores
um we don't tell vegans that yeah sorry
look i wish all that stuff worked i
don't want to eat meat this future
generation will look back at us as worse
than slavers you know because the
holocaust we're committing with the
animals but they'll have artificial
meats that taste in our healthier is
better than the real thing so allegedly
allegedly but so as a modern
knowledge worker athlete as an
intellectual athlete you want to
function like an athlete which means you
train hard
then you sprint
then you rest then you reassess you get
your feedback loop then you train some
more then you sprint again then you rest
then you reassess this idea that you're
going to have linear output just by
cranking every day at the same amount of
time same that's
that's machines you know machines should
be working nine to five humans are not
meant work nine of are not meant to work
nine to five no i agree wholeheartedly
but that's it
for people that are
working for someone there's not really
that option
so that's unfortunately the the rub
right that's kind of where my tweet
storm starts which is
first of all the first thing if you're
going to make money is that you're not
going to get rich renting at your time
even lawyers and doctors who are
charging three four 500 an hour they're
not getting rich because their lifestyle
is slowly ramping up along with their
income and they're not saving enough
they just don't have that ability to
retire
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to own a piece of a business you
need to have equity either as an owner
an investor shareholder
or a brand that you're building that
accrues to you to gain your financial
freedom
yeah and
i was really fascinated by another thing
that you were bringing up about
working for yourself that you feel in
the future whether it's 50 or 100 years
from now virtually everyone is going to
be working for themselves and i believe
the way you put it is that
the information age is going to reverse
the industrial age yeah if you go back
to hunter-gatherer times how we evolved
we basically work for ourselves we
communicated and cooperated within
tribes but each hunter each gatherer
stood on their own and then combined
their resources with the family unit but
there was no boss hierarchy hierarchy
hierarchy or you're like the third
middle manager down
in the farming age we became a little
bit more hierarchical as we had to run
farms but even those were still mostly
family farms
it's industrial work with factories that
sort of created this model of thousands
of people working together on one thing
and having bosses and schedules and
times to show up the reality is if you
have to go i don't care how rich you are
i don't care whether you're like a top
wall street banker if you have to go
if somebody has to tell you if somebody
can tell you when to be at work and what
to wear
and how to behave you're not a free
person you're not actually rich so we're
in this model now where we think it's
all about employment and jobs and
intrinsic in that is that i have to work
for somebody else
but the information age is breaking that
down
so ronald kos is an economist who has
this coast theorem a very famous theorem
but it basically just talks about
why is a company the size that it is why
is a company one person instead of 10
people instead of 100 instead of a
thousand and it has to do with the
internal transaction costs versus the
external transaction costs let's say i
want to do something let's say i'm
building a house and i need someone to
come in and provide the lumber i'm a
developer right do i want that to be
part of my company or do i want that to
be an external provider a lot of it just
depends on how hard it is to do that
transaction with someone externally
versus internally if it's too hard to
keep doing the contract every time
externally i'll bring that in-house if
it's easy to do externally and it's a
one-off kind of thing i'd rather keep it
out of the house
well information technology is making it
easier and easier to do these
transactions externally it's becoming
much easier to communicate with people
gig economy i can send you small amounts
of money i can hire you through an app i
can rate you afterwards so we're seeing
an atomization of the firm we're seeing
the optimal size of the firm shrinking
it's most obvious in silicon valley tons
and tons of startups constantly coming
up and shaving off little pieces of
businesses from large companies and
turning them into huge markets so what
looked like the small little vacation
rental market on craigslist is now
suddenly blown up into airbnb is one
example
that's a great example but what i think
we're going to see
is
whether it's 10 20 50 100 years from now
high quality work will be available
we're not talking about driving an uber
we're talking about super high quality
work will be available in a gig fashion
where you'll wake up in the morning your
phone will buzz and you'll have five
different jobs from people who have
worked with you in the past or have been
referred to it's kind of like how
hollywood already works a little bit
with how they organize for a project
you decide whether to take the project
or not the contract is right there on
the spot you get paid a certain amount
you get rated every day or every week
you get the money delivered and then
when you're done working you turn it off
and you go to tahiti or wherever you
want to spend the next three months and
i think the smart people have already
started figuring out that the internet
enables this and they're starting to
work more and more remotely on their own
schedule on their own time on their own
place with their own friends in their
own way and that's actually how we are
the most productive
so the information revolution by making
it easier to communicate connect and
cooperate is allowing us to go back to
working for ourselves and that is my
ultimate dream even when i run a company
and i have employees i always tell those
people hey i'm going to help you start
your company when you're ready because i
think that's the highest calling maybe
not everybody will get there but it
would be fine if we were even working a
10 person company or 20 person company
is way better than working in a thousand
person company a 10 000 person company
so this idea that we're all factory like
cogs in a machine who are specialized
and have to
do things by rote memorization or
instruction is going to go away and
we're going to go back to being small
groups of creative bands of individuals
setting out to do missions and when
those missions are done we collect our
money we get rated and then we rest
and reassess until we're ready for the
next sprint has there ever been a study
done on happiness and as it regards to
the size of companies
not that i'm aware but to me it's
obvious it's just obvious the smaller
the company the happier you're going to
be the more human your relations are the
less you have rules to operate under the
more flexible the more creative
the more you betray like a human just
because you're able to do multiple
things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
you